back down it looked like you do it down
with two hands Barker wheeling Anna
dumps one nice black good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
GD AK you know gets it inside the Lopez
comet inside is Jabari Parker 3 of 12
few no side to Parker he's a nice plane
I was in college he is here in the NBA
tonight he's got 20 points 5 rebounds I
do Jabari Parker might be on a quiz I
I'm not surprised only one the future
all-star Chris Dunn is played solid
areas right here 301 we've got numbers
Chris Dunn Parker is there to clean it
up
good hustle by Jabbar and here in the
early going in eight minutes you just
love his spring it is his athleticism
the turn baseline and the jam Bob Parker
had the ability he has he's got a
smaller man on him goes right by the
tune and then right there Marvin
Williams again is late getting over
Parker shake on land can't hit the
bounce and backed up by police showed up
Parker
Felicia Marie could not be anything with
him down there Mouse and a house free
cheese the villains have hammer get my
[ __ ] in there and now he's starting to
filter starters back in biggest lead was
18 there's Jabbar biggest 18 [ __ ] I
mean there's oh man poor wrinkles yeah
it was a terrific human don't be late we
eat the lead here trapped at the corner
and then fires
terrific pass by Cameron Payne across
this pass by Payne major Payne with the
nice pass Jabari with the strong finish
[Applause]
did you borrow investable
there's great wives now - off the window
harder screen that back door window
based on that was it too far it was the
past Neil they tried to get earlier when
he threw it away and he's going to go
get it even a bad shot get it behind the
back pass you through
rebound a window now pay bounced inside
uppercuts a good job of running the
floor that time rook was he losing off
the balls he couldn't make the pass now
Holliday elbow jumper short rebound but
it'd be a good acquisition for playoff
caliber teams for Jamal
fakes and nowhere to go
across the back foot at big fella eatin
179 what a pass by wind Dale Carter jr.
a strike here in Dale goes in defense
comes over and then
the back whatin it's the largest of
matches the largest they've had markers
[Music]
mr. Booker trail Ivanka watch this
little fete goes right to there and then
there's Booker comes over late that ball
kind of pops free right Jabari had a
straight line to Neal you have them seen
you move that fast as 1972 Parker that's
once asked to first easy buckets the
Bulls have had tonight
[Applause]
well situation there's the ball right
smooth eyes the fake about stolen good
defense by the gold Parker Parker run
wheel spin cycle
[Music]
[Applause]
travel
[Applause]
hmm first of all gets up in the air gets
in on us out of the way and then right
here boom extra give holiday and rhythm
tapped by Parker and he wins it in front
of Drummond holiday the fake to Bullock
and a flash by Jabari nice play by
Justin holiday with that right in front
of the officials here it is my head nice
shot fake and then a shovel pass and
Jabari knows what to do to try to deny
him the basketball as the down screen
comes you got to get some support
there's a nice pass right there as the
down screen comes because he's a catch
and shoot type of player just a little
taller outside the borders secure this
shop is badly he just first bent there
out of nowhere Beasley didn't go hard
after and Jabari did for the screen now
burst in goes to Lopez at that time
taken away by Jabari Parker up and race
[Applause]
[Music]
they're in a zone now hole two-three
zone and that's what they do they move
right there
this is the Parker dump right here to
watch this commands rebound right here
you go straight up Nelson corner
Blakeney punches it out by antonio blake
haul it on get Napier's guarding up huge
size advantage here doesn't matter I'm
glad they saw it because he had made on
him the whole time you see this out and
replay by Jabari Parker shut off but
saved by chefs
Harrison bounces to Parker
big boy jams it close this one out lead
is for marker oh what a move he went
through a couple of defenders and would
not be denied a nice attack throws the
ball ahead in between two cleveland
defenders and then the strong dunk
randall nowhere to go
parker gets it back and flushes it down
the other way Jabari Parker with a
double pump slam on the Wizards side
thought that it was a travel marker with
a shakin bacon
cogs and slammed
this is known back in his hometown of
Chicago over Lowrey market double team
Bobby swings it to Parker for another
slam
[Music]
Parker another slam by Jabari Parker
those were the first two points by the
way for Bradley field at the quarter the
nice pass to Parker and he flushes it
down underneath Parker gets fouled score
the field goal he will go to the line
here come the Wizards again it's their
third opportunity to extend this lead
marker
Jabari spins and slams it in and that
will be called for a timeout and Jabari
Parker with his offensive rebounding and
now put back he'll has 16 points big
dumpling underneath as was it score
Parker gets zou is in recent history
table have a stroke breaks down the
hypocrisy person behind the
[Music]
Wizards lead from 11:00 down to four
veal racing towards the baseline
mentioned Jackson he's got ten points in
four minutes good move by Parker Newsome
and finishes he's got a thick body too
that knows how to use it so just sizing
up Devin Harris drives realize no one's
coming over Powell stays at home and
Jabari Parker with a strong finish it's
good to see him out and thank you we'll
be looking for that he is 5 for 5 from
three-point range but saved by the
Wizards that time to Troy Brown here's
Tafari marker for the nother vicious
slam 22 points in the paint for
Charlotte the Wizards have 12 in the key
Jabari Parker with a big finish
losing a tries out and Washington will
play this fraud again next Friday night
in DC Jabari Parker inside with a big
finish Parker with a crossover Ariza
fumbled it now he fakes and drives good
pass for Jabari Parker more to so good
but gives it up to Greene who's even
more open to these issues Parker the
offensive rebound the flush all of the
game he's 1 for 6
Parker drives somebody got a hand on it
and he flushes it down
exclamation point from Jabari Parker
Jabari miss bullying his way to the
basket
Kemba Walker not happy Derrick columns
Parker it's a nice job to take advantage
of the number you know with a step back
just wouldn't go offensive rebound
Parker with the finish is that this
season it's it seems like another life
method
Parker side steps and flushes
[Applause]
shot no good and Troy brown pulls it
down being chased by Noah and now
underneath for Jabari Parker
nice the look from Troy brown as rebound
by Thomas Bryan putting on the
afterburners with a finish Jabari Parker
[Applause]
Jabari Parker with a nice finish three
seconds a wizard to call the floor and
instead they get to turn over with
Portis Bobby
nice pass for Parker you it early was
the two former poles hook up shadow
Randall rebound Parker puts it back in
Jabari Parker Parker splits defenders
and finishes at the rim
that took away what could have been an
easy basket you missed that shot now the
numbers favor the lake for the deuce to
cut it to 11 8 using a tall farm and he
missed the layup and Thomas Bryant is
there just fifth rebound the other adage
Jabari Parker Bobby Portis of the battle
down low wouldn't get it to roll in
Parker the rebound finishes with a flush
and the foul shot at first to get a
rebound and first to get a rebound it is
just that's just an act of scorn a
basketball just because somebody else
shot the ball doesn't mean the play is
over with Korver underneath so fair no
if he was held that Sam Dekker was able
to get the ball Sam with a spinning move
for Parker and a big finish for Jabari
Parker the ball on the side great first
bus and Becker to get a sense of re-park
that save great play good hustle McCray
down court feeds for Parker store the
field goal and he'll go to the line
keeping it alive
wizards down court nice feed here at
Parker able to get the hoop almost stole
employed
close parker baseline puts it up and
slams it in timeout Utah Jabari Parker
will not be denied nice rebound by
Jabari pushing it up the court spins
inside bishops lab that has come to be
passe it's gonna be a dark shadow short
jumper rolls up chip up would not go
rebound Parker puts it on the floor and
finishes with a slam double duty on this
you have seven footer six nine it's good
matter
take that get it call the foul jus look
at that I mean I'm a power for averaged
a double-double in my career before
Denver did not for the fifth straight
years good play by Parker to pick off
that screen role Roy brown jr. that's
another finish at the rim for Jabari
Parker what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content